according to scitec daily did you know
watching TV is actually good for you
well then I must be great yeah I think
you're a genius
well we're used to hearing that we
should you know limit kids screen time
but a new study shows watching TV can
actually be cognitively beneficial for
young children under specific
circumstances uh the age the show should
be age appropriate there should be any
other screens on in the room that are
distracting and and it's most important
that they watch with your parents or
adults so they can have conversations
about it oh I grew up on Ricky Lake on
Rosie on Oprah
and look at me at me hello
and you you raise yourself
because my babysitter